THEN WHEN I CALL
TO ORDER THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH -- WE
IT TIME DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE SHOW BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
SO I DO SEE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE CENTER DOT AND YOU ARE ALSO
FOR STEP ON THE FILE.
SO WELCOME.
AND IF WE THAT ITEM -- BEFORE
YOU BEGAN PLEASE MAKE A FEW
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT SO FIRST OF
ALL WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON OUR
AGENDA WE HAVE ONE ITEM LIKE
CONSENT THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB -- SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR I THINK
IN THIS GROUP HOPEFULLY AMONG
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
ARE I WILL GO OVER THEM AGAIN.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS SUBCOMMITTEE SB
TWO FOURTEEN BY SENATOR DODD
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PER SHEET --
TIME AND ATTENTION THAT THIS
AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THE COOPERATION.
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING TODAY.
SB TWO FOURTEEN WILL ENSURE
CONTINUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS PROGRAM.
THAT SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONS --
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES WITH
DISABILITIES FROM INSTITUTIONS
SETTING BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY.
INDIVIDUALS WHO VOLUNTARILY A
ROLE IN ROLE IN THE C. C. T.
PROGRAM.
RECEIVE TRANSITION COORDINATION
IT CARE PLANNING HOME SET UP AND
MODIFICATIONS FAMILY CARE GIVER
TRAINING AND MANY OTHER SERVICES
THAT ENSURE.
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS THRIVE IN
IN IN A HOME BASED SETTING.
ALTHOUGH FEDERAL FUNDING CUT.
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CC T. WAS
SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO SHORT TERM
EXTENSIONS ARE GRANTED.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ACTIVELY CONSIDERING -- AN
EXTENSION OF THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE INTENSIVE AND
TIME CONSUMING WORKS IT TAKES TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION AN
INDIVIDUAL BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
INSTABILITY IN FUNDING CAN MEAN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION.
IN LANGUISHING IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING.
SB TWO FOURTEEN WILL ENSURE
THREE THINGS. ONE MEDI CAL
BETTER FISHERIES LIVING IN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS FOR
LONGER THAN NINETY DAYS CONTINUE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO BE TRANSIT
TRANSITION BACK.
INTO A COMMUNITY SETTING.
CALIFORNIA TO CALIFORNIA CAN
COMPLY WITH THE OLMSTEAD
DECISION REQUIRED STATE TO
ENABLE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
TO LIVE IN THE MOST INTEGRATED
SETTING POSSIBLE.
ED THREE THE STATE CAN REALIZE
SAVINGS SINCE COMMUNITY LIVING
IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IT
LOOKS LIKE OR MORE THAN WHAT I'M
LET'S SEE TODAY OR MAYBE NOT --
MARYLAND CROSSWIND LIBBY SANCHEZ
IN KERR CHILD'S THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITNESS
SUPPORT SIX MINUTES COLLECTIVELY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- LIBBY SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY INNOVATIONS I
JUST WANNA START BY EXPRESSING
AN ENORMOUS -- AND AND SINCERE
GRATITUDE TO YOUR STAFF FOR THE
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF WORK THEY
PUT IN -- TO HELPING US CRAFT
THIS BILL IT'S A MUCH BETTER
BILL THAN IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HAD
SHE NOT PUT IN NOT EFFORTS TO
WERE JUST REALLY DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE I'D LIKE.
TO INTRODUCE OUR STAR WITNESS
MARILYN CROSSLAND WHO IS ONE OF
THE MORE THAN THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONED IN
CALIFORNIA VIA THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS PROJECT
AND PROGRAM AND WHICH WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITIONED WITHOUT.
BEING ABLE TO KEEP THE PROGRAM
RUNNING THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
HELLO.
HI TOM.
I GOT SICK I THOUGHT I HAD THE
STOMACH JUST OF STOMACH FLU AND
BUT IT WOUND UP FORCING THEM I
WANT UP INTO A FACILITY WHERE
THEY HAD TO TAKE CARE OF ME.
AND THE DAY AFTER I WAS THERE
FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS I HAD NO
PLACE TO GO.
AND SO I'M ONE OF THE WORKERS
AND SHE STARRED TRANSITIONING ME
TO FIND A HOUSE AND EVERYTHING
AND I'VE BEEN THERE NOW. FOR
FOUR YEARS.
AND DOING WONDERFULLY WELL.
CONDITIONS NOT EASY COMING OUT
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF PAPERWORK
AND EVERYTHING BUT I WAS FINE
WITH THAT.
AND VERY HAPPY WITH WHERE WE ARE
AND IT'S GOT ME STRONGER.
I WALK WITH A WALKER MOST THE
TIME BUT I CAN OTHER TIME SO.
BUT THE SO WHEN I THOUGHT I HAD
LOST EVERYTHING.
AND NOTHING NOWHERE TO GO NOW
THIS SAVED MY LIFE IT REALLY DID.
AND IT'S SO MUCH BETTER AND SO
I'M REALLY HAPPY AND GREAT
ROOMMATE AND IT'S A WONDERFUL
PLACE TO LIVE SO.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATED.
YEAH IT'SWONDERFUL SO.
DR BANDMEMBERS KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA --
I TWO ONE ACCO -- WITH LIBBY HAD
SAID ABOUT TO THE GREAT -- STAFF
WORK -- ON CRAFTING THE BILL --
I THINK IT IS A VERY GOOD STRONG --
BILL I I REALIZE THIS IS NOT A
FISCAL COMMITTEE -- BUT THE THE
FISCAL SIDE AND THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT PART
OF IT -- AND DOCTOR PAN IS
YOU'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THIS ISSUE AND IN SUB THREE
I THINK YOUR QUITE AWARE OF THE
POTENTIAL SAVINGS -- FOR EVERY
PERSON THAT GETS -- TRANSITIONED
OUT PURSUANT TO THIS PROGRAM
THERE'S ABOUT A SIXTY THOUSAND
AVERAGE SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
SAVINGS TO THE STATE PER
INDIVIDUAL -- PER YEAR AND SO I
I WENT BACK AND TOOK A LOOK
AGAIN AT THE THE LAST YEAR'S --
NUMBERS -- FOR THE PROGRAM AND
SO THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN NUMBERS --
WHAT'S ABOUT AT TEN POINT. THREE
MILLION DOLLAR -- A SPLIT THEM.
EXPENSE COSTS -- BY THE STATE
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE AND THAT
WAS GENERAL FUND AND EIGHT POINT
SEVEN WERE FEDERAL FUNDS -- AS
CENTER DOT IT NOTED TO THE
FEDERAL MONEY FOLLOWS THE PERSON
DOLLARS FLOWING FROM THAT BUT
WHAT WAS QUITE STRIKING IS THE
SAVINGS THAT COME FROM THAT AND
AS THE DEPARTMENTS ESTIMATES
BINDER RECOGNIZE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN IN.
NET SAVINGS -- THROUGH THIS --
PROGRAM SO NOT ONLY THE PEACE
THAT -- YOU JUST HEARD
EXPLAINING THE IMPORTANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS FOR THEM TO BE ABLE --
TO MOVE OUT OF INSTITUTIONS AND
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
HOMES THERE SIGNIFICANT -- COST
SAVINGS -- IJUST WANTED TO NOTE --
ONE OTHER PIECE THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHY THIS BILL
IS NEEDED FIRST OF ALL THIS WAS
A PROGRAM THAT WAS NOT CODIFIED --
IN STATE LAW AND THIS BILL WOULD
NOW CODIFY THAT AND AND AND LAY
OUT REALLY ALL OF THE STANDARDS --
FOR ELIGIBILITY HERE IN -- IN
THE PROGRAM -- AND I I WANT
OTHER -- NOTE ON THIS IS THAT --
THE THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
LOOKING TO THE WAIVER AND DOC
PLANNING NO YOU CAN YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY THEY HEAR THE
CHALLENGES WITH -- THE WAIVER
THAT THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
FULL SCOPE OF SERVICES THAT ARE
OFFERED THROUGH THE CCT --
PROGRAM AT ALL BUT IMPORTANTLY
ONLY 11% OF THE CCT PARTICIPANTS
ARE ENROLLED IN THAT THE WAIVER
ANYWAY SO THERE'S A VAST
POPULATION THAT WOULD BE SERVED
BY THE CCT PROGRAM THAT'S NOT --
OTHERWISE -- SERVED -- I WILL
JUST ALSO SAY THAT -- THIS BILL
IS IMPORTANT FOR ONE OF THE
REASON AND THAT IS THE FEDERAL
FUNDING -- THAT IS OUT THERE
THIS IS PAN BELIEVE IT OR NOT A
LARGELY BIPARTISAN ISSUE -- IT
WAS EXTENDED. FOR THREE MONTHS --
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR AND
THEN THERE WAS ANOTHER SIX MONTH
EXTENSION -- THROUGH THE END OF
THE YEAR WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT AS
THE FEDERAL BUDGET GET WORKS
GETS WORKED OUT.
THAT THIS WOULD STAY -- WITH IN --
THE THE FEDERAL SHARE FUNDING
HOWEVER SHOULD IT NOT THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE THAT THE STATE
WOULD OPERATE THIS PROGRAM
STANDING ALONE AND WE SUBMIT
WITH THE SAVINGS THAT STILL --
WITHOUT THE FEDERAL FUNDING THE
SAVINGS THAT IT GENERATES WOULD
BE TO THE TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
STATE FOR THE CONTINUATION OF
THE OF THE PROGRAMS WE ARE CHAIR
I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JAIME SOTO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER OF KERN COUNTY WE
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THIS SERVICE
AND WE ASKED THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I AM SHORT DEBBIE TELLS FROM
CHOICE AN AGING.
AND THIS WAS ONE OF OUR
TRANSITIONS MARILYN AND I JUST
WANT.
TO POINT OUT.
SOMEBODY CAN LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
IN AN INSTITUTION YOU CAN MAKE
THAT HAPPEN AND I I LOVE SENATOR
DODD AND I THINK YOU FOR THIS.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
HANNAH CONTROLLERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
OVER SENATE'S PARTICIPATED.
SIXTY TWO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NINE QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- WELL WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO WE CAN'T MOVE IT
YET -- WILL HOPEFULLY SOME MORE
MEMBERS A SHOP AT THE ANSWER BUT
YOU KEEP.
SO -- CENTER DOT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- I THINK WAS MENTIONED
BY A WITNESS CENTURY WHERE WE
ALSO HEARD -- BUDGET REQUEST
RELATED TO THIS AND I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THE THIS IS ABOUT
FIRST OF ALL STABILIZING THE
PROGRAM IN A WAY BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY WITH THE FEDERAL
FUNDING BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT AND I THINK WE ASK THESE
QUESTIONS ALSO AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE S. CHALLENGED LA --
AND FINANCES A IT'S A YOU KNOW
IS THAT IT'S AN SHOULD BE SCORED
AS AN THAT SAVINGS ACTUALLY
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS THE
ALTERNATIVE UNFORTUNATELY WOULD
BE IS THAT SOMEONE TO HAVE TO BE
IN AN INSTITUTION IT'S NOT AS IF
WEALTHY ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
IT WOULD COST ANY MONEY TO THE
STATE SO -- WITH THAT -- WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOURS GREAT STAFF -- FOR
HELP US OUT MAKE A BETTER BILL
HERE THANK YOU KAY AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH MY STAFF AND EXCEPT
IN A MINUTE SO WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO WHEN AT THAT POINT
TIME WILL TAKE A MOTION AND AND
A VOTE BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR BEING HERE THANK. TWO THREE
FOUR OKAY ONE MORE.
AND WE HAVE -- OKAY -- SO SIR
RUBIO I THINK YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING NEXT HOWEVER BEFORE
YOU LEAVE YOUR SEAT I SEE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND SO I ASKED THE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL STEPS CORN.
CAM HERE PAN IS HERE STONE.
STONE IS HERE DORADO.
DRAWS -- HERE GROWTH.
GROVES HERE HER TADO LEYVA
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE OKAY SO WE JUST HEARD
ONE BILL AND SUB COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE SENATOR RAZA WAS GOING
TO MAKE A MOTION IN THIS.
OKAY.
OKAY SO -- THE MOTION IS -- BEEN
MADE AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AN AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AS
PRIDE IN THE ONE SB TWO FOURTEEN
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PAN HI AND I STONE.
STONE I DORADO DRAWS -- I'D
GROWTH GROUP I HEARD TOTO LEYVA
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
BY THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT BUT
WE'LL KEEP IT ON THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO SERVICE ARE YOU READY
OKAY SO YES WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP 538% -- RUBIO
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
WITNESSES ARE HERE.
WITH THIS ISN'T HERE YET.
UP THERE HERE OKAY EXCELLENT.
I'M SORRY I JUST GOT HERE.
THIS YEAR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING ON SB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT A BILL THAT
WILL HELP PARENTS AND EDUCATORS
IDENTIFY ELECTRIC CIGARETTES AND
REDUCE THEIR USE BY STUDENTS
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURERS TO SUBMIT.
A PHYSICAL DESCRIPTION IMPORTANT
GRAPH OF EACH TYPE OF DEVICE A
CELL IN CALIFORNIA TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO POST THIS
DESCRIPTION AND PHOTOGRAPH ON
THE WEBSITE AND IT ALSO REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT A
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO
NOTIFY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IMPAIRED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ONLINE
AS WELL DESPITE LAWS PROHIBITING
THE SALE OF ELECTRONICS
CIGARETTES TO PEOPLE UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS EACH.
I AND THEIR USE IS RAPIDLY
INCREASING ACCORDING TO A REPORT
RELEASED BY THE UNITED STATES
FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION AND
NOVEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE THAN THREE
POINT SIX MILLION.
ARE MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORT USING EAST
DEVICES WITHIN THE PAST THIRTY
DAYS.
THIS IS AN INCREASE OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION STUDENTS AS THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
DEVICES PRODUCED IN RECENT YEARS
HAVE GONE UNDER THE RADAR
BECAUSE THEY LOOK VERY DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT WE'RE USED TO IN
PARTICULAR THE USB FLASH DRIVES.
OR PENS THIS MAKES IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT FOR
PARENTS AND EDUCATORS TO
IDENTIFY THESE DEVICES HAVE
BROUGHT TO SCHOOL OR A OR ANY
OTHER PLACE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP
THESE DEVICES OUT OF THE HANDS
OF OUR STUDENTS THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPOSE A REASONABLE FEE.
ON ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURERS TO COVER THE
DEPARTMENTS COSTS OF
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM.
I AS A TEACHER MYSELF I CAN TELL
YOU I'M NOT A SMOKER SO I
WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT THIS DEVICE
IS WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE WHAT THEY
ARE OR HOW THEY SMELL WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO TO DO SOME OF MY
WITNESSES.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS MERITED
BURKE MAN CHRISTINE CHEST MEANT
TO MEMBERS OF THAT GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION PARENTS AGAINST.
VAPING E. CIGARETTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO SIX MINUTES TOTAL
MAXIMUM BUT THE I THINK THE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE CHESSON AND
I'M WITH PARENTS AGAINST VAPING
E. CIGARETTES A GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT OF PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
PROVIDING THE EPIDEMIC OF TEEN
VAPING.
BUT TODAY I MOSTLY HERE IS THE
PARENTS.
MY OWN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SON IS
NOW FACING NICOTINE ADDICTION
THANKS TO DISCRETE APPEALING
DEVICES POPULARIZED BY JEWEL.
WHEN I FIRST FOUND THE SMALL
PLASTIC CAP AN EMPTY CAPSULE IN
MY SON'S ROOM?
I THOUGHT THEY WERE SOMETHING
LEFT VER FROM ONE OF HIS
ELECTRONIC DEVICES OR PERHAPS
THE PENCIL LEAD CASE OR CANDY
CASE.
IN A TEENAGE BOYS ROOM THERE'S
LOTS OF AN IDENTIFIABLE TRASH
AMONG PILES OF DIRTY CLOTHES AND
PAPERS.
YOU NEVER KNOW WITH WHAT'S GOING
ON THERE.
WHEN I FOUND THESE ITEMS AGAIN I
CONFRONTED HIM AND THE TRUTH
CAME OUT?
THEIR CONSTANT USE OF THE SNEAKY
EASILY HIDDEN DEVICES IS
VIRTUALLY UNDETECTED BY TEACHERS
AND PARENTS JUST LIKE ME AND
SENATOR RUBIO.
KIDS WERE WE LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE TOLD US THAT IN
SOME CASES UP 280% OF THEIR
FRIENDS ARE REGULARLY USING
FLAVORED E. CIGARETTES.
IT'S NORMAL EVERYONE DOES IT
THEY SAY.
BIG TOBACCO HAS SNAPPED BACK
INTO THE ADDICTION BUSINESS
THROUGH THE TECH INDUSTRY SIDE
DOOR LURING MILLIONS OF TEENS
AND YOUNG ADULTS DOWN THIS
PROFITABLE PATH.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT A KID WHO
JULES IS FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO BEGIN SMOKING REGULAR
CIGARETTES THAN A KID WHO DOES
NOT YOU'LL.
HAD I KNOWN SOONER WITH THE
SLEEK LITTLE PLASTIC CAPSULES
AND TECH PRODUCTS WERE PERHAPS I
COULD HAVE HELPED MY SON SOONER
AND PREVENTED FULL BLOWN
ADDICTION. FOR WHICH SHE IS NOW
SEEKING TREATMENT.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SORRY.
THANK YOU SIR MY NAME IS
MEREDITH BERKMAN AND I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF PARENTS AGAINST A. B.
E. CIGARETTES -- AND AS PRISTINE
SAID I'M NOT HERE BECAUSE I'M A
DOCTOR I'M NOT HERE BECAUSE MY
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT I'M NOT
HERE BECAUSE I'M GOVERNMENT OR
POLITICS.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I'M AN
ACTIVATED MOTHER OF FOUR KIDS
AND I STARTED THIS GROUP LESS
THAN A YEAR AGO.
BECAUSE I FOUND THAT MY
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SON AND HIS
FRIENDS WERE CHILLING AND I
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
AND IT'S A VERY COMMON STORY WE
FOUND -- THESE PLASTIC CAPS WE
FOUND CHARGERS THAT WE THOUGHT-WERE FROM TELEPHONES A FROM CELL
PHONES AND WE WENT ONLINE AND
BEGAN TO CONNECT THE DOTS IT WAS
IMMEDIATELY CLEAR.
THAT WE ARE FACING AND EXPERTS
WILL WILL TELL YOU THE VOTE THE
LARGEST ADOLESCENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS UP WE'VE HAD FOR DECADES.
THIS IS AN AMAZING BILL BECAUSE
IT IS SO INCREDIBLY PRACTICAL
WE'RE A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
WERE YOU KNOW OPERATING HERE AND
IN NEW YORK AND AND MANY OTHER
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND THE THING THAT PARENTS SAY
TO US TIME AND AGAIN I WISH I'D
KNOWN WHAT I WAS LOOKING.
FOR I WISH I'D KNOWN WHEN I
FOUND A CHARGER THAT WAS LARGER
THAN NORMAL WHAT THAT WAS OR HOW
COULD HE HAVE BEEN DOING THAT IN
HIS ROOM UNDER MY NOSE.
I WAS THERE ALL THE TIME AND I
DIDN'T SMELL ANYTHING I DIDN'T
SEE ANYTHING.
WE GET CALLS FROM EDUCATORS.
LIKE SENATOR RUBIO WE GET CALLS
FROM PEDIATRICIANS AND THE
SADDEST CALLS OF ALL COME FROM
PARENTS WHO ARE DESPERATE
BECAUSE THEIR KIDS ARE NOW
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
AND HAD THEY KNOWN WHAT THESE
DEVICES LOOKED LIKE IT WOULD
HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLY.
PRACTICAL AND NONPARTISAN AND%
URGENTLY NEEDED AND TIMELY BILL
THAT WILL HELP OTHER PARENTS ALL
OVER THE STATE SO THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING.
FOR AND THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IF THEY HAVE A PROBLEM THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AFTER MY ROBINSON KAISER
PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
RECEBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
A SINGING NUN QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBER SIR GROWTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS -- I KNOW THE VAPING
ISSUEIS JUST YOU KNOW HOT ON
THE PRESS IS TODAY BUT SO I DID
IT EASY GOOGLE SEARCH -- AND IT
JUST ALL AS I TYPED IN WAS YOU
KNOW VERY BEING AND IT SHOWED UP
SET UP SO IN IT DID SHOW UP
STUFF THAT LOOK LIKE A CHARGER
LOOK LIKE A PAN.
LOOK LIKE A LIKE A U. S. B. COR --
PORT LIKE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
CARRY.
SO I GUESS TWO QUESTIONS ONE IF
YOU CAN DO A GOOD EASY GOOGLE
SEARCH AND HAVE IT -- WHAT WHAT
WHAT MAKES YOUR BILL DIFFERENT
OTHER AND I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
REPORTED TO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT I GUESS MY SECOND
QUESTION A FOLLOW UP ON THAT IS?
WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH GOING TO DO WITH IT?
THAT WITH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WELL FIRST OF ALL THIS
SUGGEST -- IS A BEGINNING OF AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM AND I'LL
TELL YOU ANYBODY CAN GOOGLE
SEARCH.
BUT THAT WOULD IMPLY THAT ALL OF
US ARE LOOKING I DON'T HAVE
CHILDREN SO AS AN EDUCATOR I
NEVER EVEN THOUGHT THAT THESE
ITEMS EXISTED AGAIN UNLESS
YOU'RE ACTIVELY LOOKING YOU
WOULDN'T SEE IT.
SO OUR HOPE IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CAN
PUT TOGETHER.
A VISUAL EVERY TIME I NEW
PRODUCT COMES TO THE MARKET THAT
WE CAN SEND OUT -- TO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND BY WAY OF THE IF
EXAMPLE -- AS AN EDUCATOR WE
HAVE STAFF MEETINGS EVERY WEEK
AND SO ON MY HOPE IS THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE AMEND
EVERY TIME THEY GO TO STAFF
MEETING AND ANYTIME THAT THERE
IS NOT A NEW DEVICE.
THEY CAN -- MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
TEACHER KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT TO
LOOK -- FOR SO SO THAT IT'S
DIFFERENT AND NOT AGAIN WE'RE
GONNA BE VERY SPECIFICALLY PUT
IN THE INFORMATION THE HOUNDS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO THAT PASSED
DOWN TO TEACHERS.
AND WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH WILL DO IS JUST.
ADMINISTER THAT THAT THE PROGRAM
IN TERMS OF PUTTING IT ON A
WEBSITE AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS INFORMATION.
SO ONCE IT'S GIVEN THIS
PHOTOGRAPH FOR DESCRIPTION IS
GIVEN TO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE PUBLIC HEALTH US
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
GOING TO DISSEMINATE THAT DOWN
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS YES NUMBER
ONE OR NUMBER TWO WE HOPE THAT
THEY HAVE A WEBSITE.
PARTICULARLY GOING STRAIGHT TO
TO TO BACK OR THEY CAN SEE THIS
PRODUCT IN CASE ANYBODY WANTS.
TO TO INQUIRE WE CAN REFER THEM
TO A WEBSITE OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I SWEAR I THINK THE SENATOR FOR
BRING IT FORWARD I THINK THIS IS
A FANTASTIC BILL.
YOU KNOW AS WE GO THROUGH LIFE
THINGS CHANGE WHEN MY GIRLS WERE
LITTLE -- WE WENT TO A CLASS --
MY HUSBAND AND I AND OTHER
PARENTS ON WHERE TO LOOK FOR
DRUG PARAPHERNALIA -- THAT OUR
KIDS COULD BE HIDING OR WHATNOT
AND NOW WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
VAPING AND THIS SORT OF THING SO
I JUST APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS SO THAT WE KNOW AS
PARENTS.
AND WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE SAFE SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
A CENTER STONE THANK YOU --
SENATOR AND I'M ALSO -- VERY
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE TO THE BILL --
TOO MANY YOUNG CHILDREN ARE.
GETTING HOOKED ON NICOTINE AFTER
DECADES OF SEEING A DECLINE --
BUT COULD YOU JUST ELABORATE
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH IS CAN BECOME
THE BENEFICIARY OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE COMING ON
THE MARKET TO DELIVER NICOTINE --
COULD YOU SHOULD POINT TO ME IN
YOUR BILL.
THE THE LANGUAGE THAT MANDATES
THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS TO
COMMUNICATE THOSE IMAGES TO ALL
THE TEACHERS WITHIN THE SCHOOL --
I TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
JUST NOT.
THROWING ANOTHER MANDATE OUT
THERE THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH SENDS OUT THIS MASS EMAIL.
WHICH IS ONE OF MANY HUNDREDS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROBABLY GET
AND THEY JUST KIND OF PUSHED OFF
THE SIDE OF A TAKE A SERIOUS
HAVING SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AS
WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY.
THAT IT REALLY BECOMES A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
TEACHERS ARE AWARE OF THESE
DIFFERENT NICOTINE DELIVERY
MODALITIES.
SO THAT THEY ARE AWARE OF IT
THEY CAN SPOT IT AND THEY CAN DO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO TRY.
TO ALERT THE PARENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT -- I JUST WANNA
JUST -- INSURER.
OR AT LEAST GIVE YOU MY COMMAND
THAT I'LL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THAT IT'S REALLY TIGHT SO IT
GETS DONE OF COURSE WHEN I IT
YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS BILL UP I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT IT'S DONE WELL AND DOWN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
BEEN UP TAKE -- BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TOBACCO
CONTROL.
PROGRAM SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
AND FIGURE OUT TOGETHER WHAT.
IS THE BEST I WAY FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE CONCERNS
ARE TAKEN CARE OF APPRECIATE IT
WITH A BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MOTION BY
CENTER STONE -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SEEN ON FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD MAKE NOTE -- THAT -- THE
BILL DOES STATE -- QUOTE THE
DEPARTMENT CHAU CONDUCTED PUBLIC
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO NOTIFY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND PARENTS ASIANS THAT PHYSICAL
DESCRIPTIONS AND PHOTOGRAPHS
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE
AVAILABLE ON INTERNET WEBSITES
SO.
I THINK THERE'S A DIRECTIVE TO
THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH.
TO INFORM -- SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND PAN ORGANIZATIONS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT THE
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE AT THE THE PART PUBLIC
HEALTH WEBSITE NATO AND ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT CERTAINLY -- YOU
CAN CERTAINLY GOOGLE AND PICK UP
IMAGES OF THESE DEVICES BUT IF
YOU GOOGLE SOMETHING YOU DON'T
KNOW WE GOT THE IMAGE OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEVICES RIGHT SO I
MEAN THEY'RE CONSTANTLY EVOLVING
TO CHANGING -- AND FORTUNE WE DO
KNOW -- THAT -- MANY OF THEM
LOOK VERY MUCH LIKE OTHER COMMON
THINGS LIKE USB DRIVES AND OTHER
THINGS SO THEY'RE NOT
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNISABLE SO I
ACTUALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE ONE PLACE.
WHERE YOU CAN GO AND FIND THIS
IT'S BECAUSE I THINK I GOOGLE I
MAY FIND SOME DEVICES MAY NOT
FIND OTHERS AND SO?
BEING BEING IN ONE PLACE AND
THEN HAVING THAT.
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN SO THAT
PARENTS AND SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
OTHERS CAN KNOW WHERE TO GO TO
FIND THIS AND SAID HAVING TO
SEARCH ON THEIR OWN HEY I SAW
SOMETHING IS THAT SOMETHING -- I
THINK IS REALLY GREAT SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS BILL AND AND CERTAINLY --
VERY SUPPORT THE BILL.
YES CENTERS CENTER STONE THE
FIGURE RESEARCH HERE ON PAGE
NINETY EIGHT I'M LOOKING AT
LINES TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY SIX
AND AND AGAIN I COMPLIMENT YOU
ON WHAT YOU'RE TRYING OUT TO DO
PAGE.
THREE OF YOUR BILL SB -- FIVE
THIRTY WE WE BASICALLY HAVE AN
HOUR EACH CAMPAIGN TO NOTIFY
DISTRICTS THAT'S FINE IF YOU
JUST TIGHTEN UP THAT LANGUAGE IN
HEARING NEXT HEARING THAT.
THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE TO
TAKE THAT INFORMATION AND THEY
HAVE TO DELIVER TO THE TEACHERS
THE TEACHERS SEE THE IMAGE AND
WHAT THEY DO WITH THE IMAGES BUT
TO OUR SCHOOLS TEACHERS A I
THOUGHT MAKE SURE DOESN'T FALL
IN AN EMPTY.
CATEGORY IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
OF ALL PLUS FOR EMAILS EVERYBODY
GETS COULD I THINK YOU'RE BILLS
IMPORTANT I DON'T WANT. TO GET
90% THEY'RE NOT GONNA HOW 2%
THERE.
SENATOR STONE THANK YOU FOR THAT
AS YOU'RE EXPRESSING AYE YOUR
CONCERNS I WAS THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO THAT AND DOWN I
KNOW THAT THERE IS MANDATE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE POST ON STAFF
LOUNGES FOR EXAMPLE OSHA AND YOU
KNOW I LABOR REGULATIONS AND SO
I THINK.
I'M GOING TO ADD THAT PROVISION
THAT THEY HAVE TO POSTED IN
EVERY STAFF LOUNGE IN EVERY
SCHOOL AND I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD.
TAKE CARE OF YOUR CONCERN BUT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
NAY SAYING ALL THE QUESTIONS SO --
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
CENTERS ON THAT BUT WHICH LIKE
THE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST
REALLY QUICKLY YESTERDAY ANOTHER
REPORT CAME OUT OF OTHER
PRODUCTS AND I JUST SAW
SOMETHING THAT LOOKS LIKE A A
STAPLER.
A FLASHLIGHT AND AND IT GOES ON
AND ON AND ON AND AND AND I'M
SORRY AS AN EDUCATOR I CAN TELL
YOU THESE ARE ITEMS THAT WE
PARTICULATE USE IN SCHOOLS AND
SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR TEACHERS
ARE EQUIPPED TO RECOGNIZE.
THESE THESE ITEMS AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS --
FACTORY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI AND I STONE STONE I DORADO.
GROVE GROVE I HER TADO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
THE BILL AS SIX VOTES WILL LEAVE
FAT THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON THE ROLE FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TING AND
OTHERS FRIGHTFULLY THINKING
ABOUT SOMEONE SMOKING A STAPLER
BUT ANYWAY.
AND SEE THAT.
ONE OKAY [inaudible]
THEY ARE SO -- WE ARE WE HAVE
ONE REMAINING AUTHORED AT WE'RE
WAITING FOR THAT CENTER
HERTZBERG CLANDESTINE.
AND HE IS HERE.
PERFECT TIMING OKAY.
OFFICES ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME CENTER HERTZBERG SO WILL.
THE OF TWO BILLS BEFORE US DO
YOU WISH TAKE THEM IN THE FOLLOW
ORDER NUMBER ARE DESERVE TO TAKE
THE BILL YOU WISH TAKE UP FIRST.
MAY MAYBE SAID IT IS SINCE YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU SHERMAN SO WHICH WILL
DO IS TO TAKE UP FOR THOSE I'M
TAKING UP A FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
SEVENTY THREE OKAY SO WILL
FOLLOW OKAY MAKE IT FAST AND
WILL.
ALL RIGHT FIREFIGHTERS ITEM
NUMBER TWO AS THESE THREE
SEVENTY THREE OKAY WELCOME.
I'M BACK WITH BLOCKCHAIN
I LOVE BLOCKCHAIN.
NOT BECAUSE I LOVE BLOCKCHAIN
BUT BECAUSE I'M TRYING.
TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
MODERNIZE -- OUR GOVERNMENT WE
HAVE A TECHNOLOGY WORLD THAT
WE'RE SO PROUD OF AROUND THIS
STAGE THAT'S MOVING AT BREAKNECK
SPEED THAT'S IMPACTING
GOVERNMENT IN SUCH A
EXTRAORDINARY WAY AND I FIND
THAT IT'S E. I'M TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO PUSH THE
ENVELOPE.
WITH RESPECT -- TO AB ARE
DROPPING MORE MODERN
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN -- GIVE
PEOPLE CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
GOVERNMENT LAST YEAR WE DID THE
SHAREHOLDERS.
A BLOCKCHAIN MEASURE IN THIS
YEAR -- WITH DEALING WITH MERIT
CERTIFICATES CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS BY ADDING
A SUNSET.
OF JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BECAUSE BY THAT TIME THE WORLD
WILL CHANGE IT AGAIN UNDER
MURPHY'S LAW LIMITING THIS
MEASURE JUST AMERICA TO FOR KIDS
AND INCLUDING A REPORT BACK.
FROM THE BLOCKCHAIN WORKING
GROUP ABOUT ITS IMPACT WHICH I
THINK I AM A MEMBER -- AGAIN --
I AM SURE THAT THIS ROOM AND
MANY OF THIS ROOM HAD THE
EXPERIENCE WHEN WE NEED A
MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE FOR TAXES
HEALTH BENEFITS ARE OTHERS.
THAT OFTEN THE TIME DEADLINE
WILL GET YOU THE DETAILS FROM
THE WITNESSES HERE I DON'T TAKE
UP TOO MUCH TIME BUT IT'S CLUNKY.
IS YESTERDAY'S NEWS IT'S HARD TO
GO AND OFFICES TAKES A LOT OF
TIME THE QUESTION IS CAN WE
ADVANCE -- OUR TECHNOLOGY THE
WAY TO MAKE IT EASIER AND SO
WITH RESPECT TO MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATES THAT'S WHAT THIS
MEASURE NOW AS AMENDED -- DOES
IT TAKE TAKE SEVEN TO TEN DAYS
TO GET COPIES HERE SO THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY DYNAMIC EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY THAT PEOPLE THINK
GENERALLY IN THE CON LIMITED
CONTEXT OF BITCOIN BUT THERE'S
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT IT
REALLY HAS TO DO WITH CREATING A
SECURE.
INTERNET REALLY THE NEXT
GENERATION OF MAKING SURE THAT
RECORDS ARE SECURE AND HERE IN
AN AREA OF THE LAW WHERE WHERE
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE'RE
TRYING TO APPLY THAT TECHNOLOGY.
HERE MY WITNESSES TODAY. TO MAKE
THIS FAST OUR ALLEY MEDINA --
WITH THE BLOCKCHAIN ADVOCACY
GROUP AND ROB.
GROSS.
BLOGGER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
REMEMBER ONCE A START FIRST
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE SIX MINUTES FOR BOTH OF
THESE CELL.
OKAY SHORTER THAN THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
ROB CHRIS CLOSER WITH THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA BY PRESIDENT ON A
JOHNSON US -- APOLOGIZE THAT SHE
CANNOT BE HERE SHE INJURED HER
KNEE AND AT THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE
RIGHT NOW SO WHICH I'M SURE YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND -- THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ARE THE CUSTODIANS OF
OUR RECORDS -- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE CONSIDER THAT --
SENSE OF PRIDE IN OUR RECORDS
DATE BACK TO THE GOLD RUSH ERA
WHEN IT COMES TO PROVIDING
THOUGH ACCESS THE RECORDS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY AND REALLY
APPRECIATE CENTER HERTZBERG
INTRODUCING THE BILL -- WE
CURRENTLY UTILIZE BANK NOTE
PAPER SO IT'S A SECURE PAPER
THAT CANNOT BE.
ALTERED OR CHANGED OR REPRODUCED
AND WE'VE SEEN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS ABOUT A
USE BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY TO
ISSUE A SIMILAR TYPE OF DOCUMENT
THAT CANNOT BE ALTERED -- I WILL
LEAVE THE EXPERT A BLOCKCHAIN TO
MY LEFT HERE FOR FOR THOSE
COMMENTS BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT
HAPPENS NOW CURRENTLY IS IF YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY COME DOWN TO
OUR OFFICE YOU COME DOWN TO GET
A COPY VITAL RECORD AN OLD
PRINTER WITH A FEW MINUTES AND
IT'S YOURS.
YOU CAN WALK OUT THE DOOR IF
YOU'RE UNABLE TO DO SO YOU CAN --
ACTUALLY GET A NOTARY THE
THOUGHT OF FORM FAX IN AS A
SENATOR SAID WAIT SEVEN TODAY
TEN DAYS TO GET IT IN THE MAIL --
THAT'S NOT A VERY EFFICIENT
PROCESS WHEN FOLKS ESPECIALLY
USING MEASURE DIFFICULT TO
CHANGE OUR NAMES AT DMV OR
OTHERS AREAS SO WE BE THIS IS A
CUSTOMER SERVICE OPPORTUNITY MY
STILL MAINTAINING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE DOCUMENTS
AND THE SECURITY OF THEM -- WE
DO KNOW FROM THE WASH YOU COUNTY --
SITUATION OR A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN MARRIED
IN RENO AND THAT WE HAVE HAD
SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA DMV OFFICES ACCEPTING
THE WASHER COUNTY BLOCK CHAINS --
IT'S AN INFORMAL SURVEY SO WE
CAN IT NOTED -- BUT WE DO HAVE
HEARD SUCCESS STORIES ALREADY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND TO GIVE
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M I'M
ALLEY MEDINA I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE BLOCKCHAIN ASK THE COALITION --
WE SUPPORT SMART BLOCKCHAIN
REGULATION AND GOOD USE CASES
THE BLOCKCHAIN FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
THINK THIS IS A REALLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD ACTUALLY USE.
A BLOCKCHAIN THAT WILL INCREASE
THE SECURITY AND EFFICIENCY FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS I THINK ONE
OF THE MAIN CONCERNS ABOUT
BLOCKCHAIN IS LIKE WHAT IS THIS
BEYOND BIT COIN.
AND IS THIS REALLY SECURE AND
YES IT IS I'M PRIMARILY THE WAY
WE STORE DATA RIGHT NOW IS
HIGHLY CENTRALIZED THE CLOUD IS
JUST A BUNCH OF SERVER FARMS
YOU'VE GOT THEM ON FIRE YOU LOSE
ALL THE DATA -- THEY CAN BE
HACKED WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF A
VERY BIG PUBLIC HACKS RECENTLY
CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHT MILLION INDIVIDUALS
RECORDS.
LAST YEAR MY FITNESS PAL A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
RECORDS OF HOW MANY STEPS YOU
TOOK IN A DAY THEY KNOW NOW --
THE GREAT THING ABOUT BLOCKCHAIN
IS THAT A DECENTRALIZED AS THE
INFORMATION AND MAKES IT
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DIFFICULT
TASK -- WASHOE COUNTY USES
TIGHTEN SEAL WHICH IS RUN ON THE
THEORY I'M BLOCKCHAIN THERE ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF USERS OF
THE ASSYRIAN BLOCKCHAIN MEANING
IT'S HIGHLY DECENTRALIZED HAS
NEVER BEEN HACKED.
BY DESIGN WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO HACK.
CURRENTLY IF YOU WANTED TO YOU
KNOW FIND BIG NO PAPER AND PHOTO
SHOP IT THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO BUT LESS
DIFFICULT THAN HACKING THE
ASSYRIAN BLOCKCHAIN THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ADDED SECURITY. FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS -- IT IS IN
ADDITION OTHER COUNTRIES AND
GOVERNMENTS ARE USING THIS
UKRAINE SUITE IN.
THE STATE OF VERMONT ARE ALL
USING A BLOCKCHAIN FOR LAND
TITLE AND FOR A REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE A
SECURE IT IS EFFICIENT.
AND IT IS THE BETTER SERVICE FOR
THEIR CITIZENS OF THE UNITED
NATIONS USES ITS RIGHT FOOD
VOUCHERS FOR REFUGEES TWO
THOUSAND TEN AND TO START TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE PROVIDED
VOUCHERS FOR TEN THOUSAND
REFUGEES.
IN CAMPS IN SYRIA -- IT WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL THE REASON IT'S RUN
ENTIRE CAMPS IN JORDAN NOW AND
ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT VIA
THE WORLD FOOD PROGRAM SO THIS
IS A TEST TO TECHNOLOGY BY
GOVERNMENTS AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT IS SECURE AND EXCELLENT FOR
PROVIDING IDENTITY IDENTITY
VERIFIED INFORMATION WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE
THINK SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND WE
THINK YOU SAYS RECORDERS FOR
SUPPORTING THAT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BACK MICROPHONE PLEASE.
JUST OF TRICKLE FROM BED AML IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALEX IS A FROM SACRAMENTO
BLOCKCHAIN DEVELOPERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RIGHT AT THE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NINE A QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY A C. -- NINE SERVERS AYE
THANK YOU MUCH SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH -- OUR COMMITTEE ON
THIS ISSUE I THOUGHT THAT --
GOOD TO START OFF FIRS WITH THE
MERIT CERTIFICATES AND BE SURE
THAT -- THAT GOES WELL AND GIVEN
THE FACT THAT BIRTH AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES ARE LITTLE MORE
FINAL -- SO -- AND I THINK --
CERTAINLY IF WE PROVE THE
MARRIAGE CERTIFICATES AND OF
PEOPLE USING THAT LIKE THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN OTHER PLACES I
THINK THAN.
I THINK IT RAISES THE COMFORT
LEVEL TO THEN -- DEAL WITH THOSE
AS I APPRECIATE THAT AND ALSO --
I KNOW THAT -- YOU THE GROUP
THAT YOU ACTUALLY SERVING ON
WILL BE COMING UP OF THE REPORT
SO I THINK THAT'S CAN ALSO BE
VERY INFORMERS WELL AS WE THINK
ABOUT HOW WE EXPAND USING THIS
TECHNOLOGY -- BUT CERTAINLY
IMPROVING ACCESS TO THESE
DOCUMENTS IS SOMETHING THAT -- I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
BRING FORWARD SO WITH THAT.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT AS
FROM ABOUT OKAY EXCELLENT SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED -- TO IT
DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE SO THE BEST
A MAN TO TAKE US TO THE FLOOR --
SO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI AND I STONE.
TORONTO.
TORONTO I GROWTH.
GROUP I HER TADO HER TITLE AYE
LEYVA.
LEAVE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO
[inaudible]
HI. SEVEN THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT
BUT WILL HOLD IT ON THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR S. BEEF NUMBER THREE SORRY
NUMBER THREE SB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT EXCELLENT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE WORKED OUT WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES.
RAISED IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
WHY DID I INTRODUCED THIS BILL
AND WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO CHIEF?
WE'VE LEARNED IN MANY INSTANCES
WHERE BECAUSE THEY'RE A MERGING
SHE SERVICES FOR AMBULANCE IN
THE LIKE IS CONTRACTED OUT THERE
HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS.
THERE HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS LIVES
HAVE BEEN LOST LICENSE RIGHT
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
WITNESSES TODAY IN A MUCH MORE
ELOQUENT WAY THAT I COULD
ARTICULATE.
WHY THIS MEASURE IS SO IMPORTANT?
BUT THEY WILL TALK ABOUT.
A HAVING PUBLIC ENTITIES
ENSURING THAT A PUBLIC ENTITY A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE OR A PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIAL IS BEST SUITED
TO BE THE ONE IN CHARGE.
OF WHO DECIDES WHAT ENTITY WITH
ITS PRIVATE OR PUBLIC WHATEVER
THE ENGINEERS THAT IS SENT TO AN
EMERGENCY SCENE.
IS IN THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE PERSON WHO ARRIVES TO THE
SCENE OF AN EMERGENCY WILL DO
THE BEST JOB THEY POSSIBLY CAN
THE QUESTION.
IS WHETHER THE PERSON EVEN GETS
THE CALL TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE
IN A TIMELY MANNER WE HAD SEEN
WHICH YOU WILL HEAR TODAY GET A
LEAVE IT TO THEM.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE SO THAT IS WHY WE'VE
INTRODUCED SB UP FOR THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL PROHIBIT A
PUBLIC AGENCY FROM OUTSOURCING
ITS LOCAL.
EMERGENCY DISPATCH SERVICES TO A
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT IT'S T.
EXCEPT UNDER VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ONE OTHER
THING I HAD BEFORE I TURN IT
OVER MY RICH TEAMS -- WITNESSES
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS TO GO UP A TO
GRANDFATHER THE EXISTING
ARRANGEMENTS IN FRESNO COUNTY TO
ENSURE CONTINUED OPERATIONS
UNDER THAT EXISTING CONTRACT.
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT FRESNO'S
FIRE DEPARTMENTS ARE EMPOWERED
TO DETERMINE THE RESOURCE
DEPLOYMENT IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY MEET OR EXCEED THE
MEDICAL CONTROL POLICIES.
ESTABLISHED BY THE COUNTY HERE
WITH ME TODAY IS THE PRESIDENT.
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION.
BRIAN RICE.
AND JEFF -- MESSIN PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WITH A NUMBER OF
THEIR COLLEAGUES.
ONLY A PICTURE THIS HERE IN IT
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
PRESIDENT RICE.
THANK YOU -- SO WELCOME AND SIX
MINUTES BOTH OF YOU TOGETHER --
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN.
IN ORDER PAN AND THE HONORABLE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR BEING
ABLE TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIAN RICE AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
I'VE BEEN A THIRTY ONE YEAR
VETERAN THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
SERVICE IN HAVE SERVED IN THE
FRONT LINES ANDALSO AS A DEPUTY
CHIEF OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN FIRE
DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
MOST SACRED MISSION F
GOVERNMENT AT ANY LEVEL IS
PROTECTING THE LIVES IN THE
HEALTH OF ITS PEOPLE. FOR MORE
THAN SEVEN DECADES THAT MISSION
HAS INCLUDED PROVIDING FAST
EFFECTIVE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE RESPONSE.
THE FIRST IN OFTEN NOT OFTEN THE
FIRST IN ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL LIFE AND DEATH
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR NINE ONE
ONE IS OUR DISPATCH.
WHEN SECONDS COUNT IT'S A SWORN
DUTY OF PUBLIC FIRE AGENCIES TO
DEPLOY THE CLOSEST AND FASTEST
RESPONSE POSSIBLE THEY'RE THE
MOST DIRECT AN ACCOUNTABLE
PUBLIC SAFETY PROVIDERS SENATE
BILL?
FOR THIRTY EIGHT ENSURES THAT
THAT SECRET RESPONSIBILITY IS
NOT PASSED OFF OR COMPROMISED BY
MOTIVATIONS OTHER THAN WHAT
MATTERS MOST IN THAT IS PATIENT
CARE.
UNDER SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
PUBLIC AGENCIES WILL BE
PREVENTED FROM DIRECTLY
OUTSOURCING THIS CORE PUBLIC
SAFETY FUNCTION TO PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT ENTITIES.
IF SUCH SERVICES ARE TO BE
CONTRACTED IT CAN ONLY BE TO
ANOTHER PUBLIC ENTITY OR TO A
JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT INVOLVING
ALL THE AFFECTED PUBLIC AGENCIES
SUCH AGREEMENTS EXIST TODAY AND
ARE.
PROTECTED BY THIS MEASURE.
IN RECOGNITION THE CORE MISSION
OF PUBLIC SAFETY IN SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT DEMANDS THE HIGHEST
STANDARD OF RESPONSE FROM PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
AFTER ALL.
WE'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
ACCOUNTABLE ONLY TO THE PUBLIC
AND THE TAXPAYERS FOR WHOM WE
SERVE.
BY CONTRAST PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
INTO BE ENTITIES ARE ACCOUNTABLE
TO THEIR OWNERS FOR THE
SHAREHOLDERS.
KIND OF SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE UTILITY INDUSTRY
TODAY.
THIS CREATES A POTENTIAL FOR
MEDICAL DECISIONS BASED ON
KOSTER PROFIT RATHER THAN THE
URGENT NEED TO THE PATIENTS FEW
PUBLIC AGENCIES OF TAKING THE
RISKY STEP OF PRIVATIZING THEIR
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCH CENTERS.
IN SITUATIONS WHERE IT IS
HAPPENED THE RESULTS OF PROVEN
DISASTROUS I KNOW YOU HEAR FROM
SOME OF OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT DOES
NOTHING TO SHIELD PUBLIC
AGENCIES THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR MEDICAL CONTROL POLICIES
REQUIRED BY THEIR LOCAL.
ANSES EMS AGENCIES.
IT SIMPLY RECOGNIZES THAT
ACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC AGENCIES MUST
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR DISPATCH
IN RESPONSE MODES AT BEST
PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES.
EVERY DISPATCHING RESOURCE MODE
MUST ALWAYS MEET OR EXCEED THE
LANCER LOCAL EMSA MEDICAL
CONTROL POLICIES.
AS FIREFIGHTERS EMS IS A CORE
PART OF OUR FUNCTION YOU SIMPLY
DON'T WORK AS A FIREFIGHTER IN
THE STATE UNLESS YOU'RE AT A
MINIMUM ANY EMPTY BASIC LIFE
SUPPORT.
IN LIFE AND DEATH SITUATIONS
IT'S ALL ABOUT DEPLOYING RAPID
RESPONSE.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF LOCAL
AGENCIES FOR MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
SHOULD NOT BE CHECKED OFF TO
ANYBODY'S BOTTOM LINE ON BEHALF
OF THE THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS EMTS AND PARAMEDICS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BY VOTE
ON SB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT AND MY TURN IT
OVER.
THE ONE THING I WANTED TO SAY.
IT'S INTERESTING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THE VERY TYPE
OF SYSTEM THAT THAT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THAT OPERATES IN THE COUNTY
SACRAMENTO RECEIVED A A
OPPOSITION LETTER.
FROM THE COUNTIES GOVERNMENT A
FAIR FAIRS OFFICER IN SOME OF
THE THINGS I'M HEARING IS THAT
THIS IS A JOB KILLER.
IT IS NOT THE CASE IN SACRAMENTO
THERE'S A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP IN RESPONSE IN EACH
OF THE PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES HAVE THEIR OWN
DISPATCH TO HANDLE INNER
FISCALLY TRANSPORTS HOME TO FROM
FROM.
THE HALL FACILITY TO HOME
TRANSPORTERS A WHOLE SECTION OF
THIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NINE
ONE ONE SERVICE DELIVERY AND I
AM COMMITTED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE DISPATCH -- IN FRESNO.
IS UNAFFECTED IN LESS THAT
COMMUNITY DECIDES TO DO A
DIFFERENT MODEL IN I CAN GET
VERY PASSIONATE I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEVEN
AND A HALF NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEFF MASSON AND I SERVICE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
OUR MEMBERS REPRESENT A WIDE
RANGE OF DELIVERY MODELS OF FIRE
EMS AND PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES
FOR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR ABOUT
WHY WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TO CO SPONSOR
CENTER HERTZBERG SPELL?
THE BILL IS ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
IT WILL PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
THE HIGHEST VESSELS OF SERVICE
TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
INDEED THIS WILL BILL WILL
PREVENT HARM THAT IS A CURRENT
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT COUNTY EMS
AGENCIES CANNOT DICTATE WERE FAR
BASICALLY A MACHINIST CANNOT
CANNOT BE DISPATCHED TO A NINE
ONE ONE CALL.
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
EVEN WHEN EMS UNITS ARE CLOSER
AND THEY CAN GET THERE FASTER
SOME COUNTY AGENCIES HAVE
ENACTED POLICIES IN HIS TRUCK
PRIVATE CONTRACTED DISPATCH
SERVICES TO DELAY OR COMPLETELY
WITHHOLD MY ONE ONE CALL.
DATA FROM FAR AGENCIES ON
EMERGENCIES WITHIN CITIES OR
FIRE DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
LET ME FOCUS BRIEFLY ON TO TERMS
AND SHALL HEAR ABOUT TODAY THE
FIRST TOMB IS MEDICAL CONTROL
THE TERM REFERS TO THE AUTHORITY
OF THE COUNTY'S MEDICAL
DIRECTOR'S.
HAS OVER THE MEDICAL DECISIONS
AND CARE RENDERED AT THE TIME A
DISPATCH IN THE FIELD DURING EMS
RESPONSE.
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE COUNTY'S ROLE IN PROVIDING
MEDICAL CONTROL OF PMS SERVICES.
THE BILL DOES NOT WAIVE THE
REQUIREMENT OF EMS DISPATCH
PROTOCOLS THAT WE MUST BE
REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY THE
COUNTY'S MEDICAL DIRECTOR.
NOR DOES HIS BILL CHANGE
AFFECTED EMS DISPATCHER OPERATOR
MUST HAVE A BOARD CERTIFIED
MEDICAL DIRECTOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEDICAL OVERSIGHT.
THE SECOND TERM IS SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION WE AGREE THAT PRE
HOUSE WILLIAM AS SHOULD BE
INTEGRATED NOTHING IN THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES NOT FAR AGENCY TO
OPERATE OUTSIDE.
OF INTEGRATED COUNTY Y. DMS
SYSTEMS LIKE ALL PUBLIC SERVICES
FROM CITIES AND SERVICE AREAS
MAY BE ABLE TO DELIVER A HIGHER
LEVEL OF EMS TO THE RESIDENTS
THAN OTHERS.
BUT IT SHOULD NOT BE THE
COUNTY'S ROLE TO DELIBERATELY
AND UNILATERALLY DEPRESSED
SERVICE DELIVERY AND ONE
COMMUNITY SO THAT THE UNITS CAN
BE DEPLOYED SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
THAT COUNTY.
THE TRUCE IS -- IN SOME COUNTY
SYSTEMS THEY'RE NOT INTEGRATED A
BECAUSE DISPATCH INFORMATION HAS
NOT BEEN SURE WITH EMS PROVIDERS
AT THE SAME TIME THIS MEANS IN
NO WAY ENSURING THE CLOSEST
AVAILABLE UNITS BE ABLE TO
DISPATCH TO A CALL.
WE BELIEVE SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
IS RESULTS OF MORE INTEGRATED
SYSTEM THAT DELIVERS THE FASTEST
POSSIBLE RESPONSE WITH THE SAME
EXACT FOR LIFEGUARDS THAT CAN
HELP WITH MEDICAL CONTROL.
TODAY WE HAVE -- TREATY CHIEF
BRADLEY AND STOCKTON CHIEF ERIC
NEWMAN HERE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
WAS THE EPICENTER AND HAS BEEN
FOR THE LAST DECADE.
THESE PURCHASE OF EXPERIENCE HOW
MEDICAL EMERGENCY CARE CAN
NEEDLESSLY DELAY BECAUSE OF THE
COUNTIES DISPATCH POLICIES THEY
ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES A POOR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND I ASSUME YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE STANDING HERE RIGHT
NOW YOUR POSITION AS A SUPPORT.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRTH MISSY JOBS WITH NIELSEN
MARKS MORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY WE
DIDN'T GET A LETTER IN BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BOB MATTHEWS PRESIDENT
FIREFIGHTERS. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX
REPRESENTING SOLANO NAPA
COUNTIES WE HERE IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF GOING BE
FIREFIGHTERS LOOK AND LOCAL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JEAN START FIRE SHE CITY A LOT I
FIRE DEPARTMENT.
FULL SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU FOR
I GET AFTERNOON SCHOMBURG ASIDE.
COMMISSIONER ANY EMS -- STATE
COMMISSION IN HERE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY OAKLAND
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL FIFTY FIVE
VIRGIN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL AKITAS
FIRE CHIEF MONTEREY COUNTY
REGIONAL FIRE IN FULL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STEVE KOVACS FIRE CHIEF SCOTT
VALLEY FIRE DISTRICT ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
SENSATION CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JEREMY L<c.cyan>G WILL HERE FOR THE</c>
CITY OF ACTUAL FIRE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTING THEM THIS
DEPARTMENT STRONGLY SUPPORTS AS
BEFORE [inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
BEN JOHNSON STOCKTON FIRE
DEPARTMENT LOCAL FOUR FIVE SIX
MANAGE A GROUP STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORE GUARDIA PRESIDENT'S DOCTOR
FAR LOCAL FOUR FIVE SIX STRONGLY
SUPPORTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEP NEW JOHN DUGAN MST CENTRAL
VALLEY FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
FULL SUPPORT.
FOR THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THREE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
RODRIGUEZ FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA REPRESENT
ALAMEDA COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS
STRONG SUPPORTER MOVING FOR THIS
BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ROBBER RICKMAN MAYOR
CITY OF TRACY HERE TODAY TO SHOW
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT SHE REMEMBERS DAVID JONES
ABOUT CITIES OF SAN MARCOS
STOCKTON SAN ROSE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN YOU ARE POLICE CHIEF CITY
OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE OVERSEEING
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCH CENTER
THAT SERVES. SIX DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CALLER ID FIRE
CHIEF CITY OF CARLSBAD STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON OCCUR DAILY ASSISTANT
FIRE CHIEF CITY OF CARLSBAD IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FIRE CHIEF CHIP
DUNCANSON DUDE NEWPORT BEACH AND
COMPANY BY MY INVESTED IN SHE'S
KRISTEN THOMPSON.
BY FAR OPERATIONS CHIEF JEFF WAS
AND WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT BEFORE THIRD IT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BREAK IKE ON
TERRIO FIRE DEPARTMENT FIRE
CHIEF IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
JEFF LOPEZ IN THIS BATTALION
CHIEF WITHOUT ANY TO BEACH FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S LERI GORE
ALTHOUGH REPRESENT THE COSTA
MESA FIRE AND RESCUE DEPARTMENT
AND ALSO THE SIDE ABOUT COLLEGE
PARAMEDIC EDUCATION PROGRAM.
BOTH OF WHICH STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A LARGER ASSISTANCE GPC DAVIS
PART PART IN HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LANCE REYES CITY OF MEN SEEK
ADMINISTRATIVE CHIEF FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DAVE GRAHAM OF FIRE DIVISION
CHIEF CELLS THAT WE CAN COUNTY
FIRE AUTHORITY TRACY -- URGING
TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PATRICK VARGAS SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY FIRE THIRTY URGING
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JEFF ARMSTRONG FIRE CHIEF CITY
REAL THIS TIME ALSO REPRESENTING
THE SLAUGHTER COUNTY FIRE CHIEF
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOUG MCALLEN PARTY CITY MARINA
AND THE PRESIDENT MONTEREY
COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JIM LEHRER BORG FIRE CHIEF THE
CITY A GREEN FIELD AND OUR CITY
IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LARRY MYTHOS GET MINISTRY OF
BATTALION CHIEF FOR THE LATER
MANTECA FIRE DISTRICT FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TED PETERSON SEVEN RAN FIRE
DISTRICT REPRESENTING MARIN FIRE
CHIEF STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE MCLAUGHLIN
FIRE CHIEF IT CONSUMES FAR
DEPARTMENT REPRESENTING MY
AGENCY IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY FIRE
CHIEFS WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR CARE COMMITTEE TRACY HANSON
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF PRESIDENT
DAVID ROACH AT THE PRESENT AT
THE CALIFORNIA METROPOLITAN FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE SIXTEEN
LARGEST FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE.
SAID URGING YOUR SUPPORT ON AS
BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE CHAIR COMMITTEE ERIC
NEWMAN FIRE CHIEF CITY OF
STOCKTON.
STRONGLY STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
G. NEARLY FIRE CHIEF LATER
MEDICAL FIRE DISTRICT ALSO THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE REACHED A
SOAKING REGIONAL FIRE DISPATCH
STORY FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
UNLESS RENTAL BRADLEY ON THE
FIRE CHIEF OF SOFT COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY WHICH INCLUDES THE
CITY OF TRACY AND SALLY KING
COUNTY AND I'M.
IN IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND I'M HERE -- TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCES AND SO WE CAN COUNTY
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND ACTUALLY -- YES
IF YOU WANT TO MOVE TO THE SIDE
OR THE OUT OF THE ROOM FOR THE
OPPOSITION SAID FRONT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WELCOME SO -- SINCE THE
PROPONENTS WENT OVER TIME I WILL
GIVE YOU SEVEN MINUTES SINCE
THAT'S PRICING TIME THEY SPENT
AS WELL -- BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
USE ALL OF THE YOU DON'T WANT.
TO THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR I'M
FAIR MCDADE TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
I'M ALSO SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA --
WE ARE THE COUNTIES YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT IN THIS BILL AND AND WE
REGRETFULLY MUST OPPOSE AS
BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT WE KNOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
AND THE FINE PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
HAVE ONE VIEW ON THE BILL. FOR
COUNTIES WE SERVE -- COUNTY WIDE
OUR LOCAL EMERGENCY SERVICES
ADMINISTRATORS TO OF WHICH I
HAVE HERE WITH ME -- SERVE THE
COUNTY WIDE AND THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A PATCHWORK IN WHICH A
CITY OR FIRE DISTRICT WOULD BE
DO BE DOING THE DISPATCH BUT THE
REST OF THE COUNTY WOULDN'T BE
COVERED.
AND WHAT OUR ROLE IS AS COUNTIES
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ENTIRE
COUNTY HAS THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF SERVICE.
COUNTY WIDE IN SOME CASES THE
SECONDARY DISPATCH IS DONE BY
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT ON VERY WELL
IN OTHER CASES IS DONE BY JPA OR
EVEN ON INDEPENDENT OR PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR.
UNDER ALL THOSE CASES THERE
UNDER THE AUTHORITY AND
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THE LAMBS Là TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ADHERE TO ALL RULES AND
REGULATIOS UNDER IT FOR MEDICAL
CONTROL RESPONSE TIMES AND OTHER
THINGS.
THIS IS THE WAY WE KNOW THAT
THEIR DISPATCHING CORRECTLY WE
ALSO THE COUNTIES ARE UNDER THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES OR THE THIRTY
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND SO WE
HAVE THESE LAYERS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A PATCHWORK AND SO.
IF A CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT WERE
ABLE TO DO THEIR OWN DISPATCH
ARE COUNTIES WOULD BE STRUGGLING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE BE SERVICES
SURROUNDING THAT CITY IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
REFER REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL.
HELLO -- I'M MY NAME IS DOCTOR
CATHERINE SHE FUHRMAN PRACTICING
EMERGENCY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO THE
M. AS MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY -- I'M HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE EMS MEDICAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
NO MATTER HOW IT HAS BEEN FRAME
THIS BILL CLEARLY ELIMINATES THE
AUTHORITY OF THE LOCAL EMUS
MEDICAL DIRECTORS WHICH IS A
PUBLIC ENTITY. TO MANAGE
IMPROVING CORRECT MEDICAL
DISPATCH MEDICAL DISPATCH IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE MS
SYSTEM AND SHOULD NOT BE
EXCLUDED FROM THE OVERSIGHT OF
LOCAL EMS MEDICAL DIRECTORS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
LOCAL EMS AGENCIES MUST ADHERE
TO STRINGENT MEDICAL CONTROL
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BY THE
STATE EMS OF THE AUTHORITY WHEN
AN ACTING LOCAL POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT GOVERN
MEDICAL DISPATCHING RESPONSE
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO OPERATE MEDICAL
DISPATCH WITHOUT A HEARING TO
ESTABLISH MEDICAL CONTROL
STANDARDS.
THIS MEANS ERRORS MADE BY PUBLIC
DISPATCH AGENCIES WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO THEM M. AS MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OVERSIGHT REMEDIATION
MEANING AN INDEPENDENT DOCTOR
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO ENSURE
PROPER MEDICAL INTERVENTIONS
WERE BEING INSTRUCTED BY
DISPATCH.
THE LOCAL EMS AGENCY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO ASSURE APPROPRIATE
PRE HOSPITAL RESOURCES ARE
DISPATCHED THE LOCAL EMS AGENCY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
IF RESPONSE TIMES ARE
APPROPRIATE.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM THROUGH REMEDIATING
ERRORS ENCOUNTERED WITHIN
MEDICAL.
DISPATCH FOR EXAMPLE -- TODAY
WHEN ERRORS ARE MISSTEPS ARE
IDENTIFIED WHETHER BY PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE PROVIDERS THE LOCAL EMS
AGENCY UNDER GUIDANCE OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR EVALUATES THE
INCIDENT AND TAKES CORRECTIVE
STEPS IS NECESSARY WHICH MAY
INCLUDE POLICY CHANGES.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL EDUCATION
AND IF WARRANTED DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS BY EXEMPTING PUBLIC
AGENCIES FROM THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE M. AS MEDICAL DIRECTOR.
THESE AGENCIES SUCH AS A FIRE
DEPARTMENT MADE A POINT AND
REDEPLOY ITS RESOURCES AS IT
SEES FIT WITHOUT MEDICAL
DIRECTION.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPROMISE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BY PROHIBITING
EMUS AGENCY MEDICAL DIRECTORS
FROM THE PLANNING AND OVERSIGHT.
OF THE MEDICAL CALL CROSSING
PROCESSING MEDICAL DISPATCH AND
MEDICAL RESOURCE UTILIZATION IN
ADDITION THE BILL TIES THE HANDS
OF COUNTY ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
PREVENTS THEM FROM IMPLEMENTING.
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
COMBINATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PROVIDERS.
THIS WILL CAUSE HARM TO THE
CITIZENS TO CALL GET REGRESSION
THE EVOLUTION OF NINE ONE AM
PATIENT CARE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
BURCH I'M REPRESENTING THE
INVESTMENTS TRADERS.
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CENTRAL TENETS OF THE EMS
ACT IN THE WAR NINE ONE ONE ACT
OR THE CREATION OF PLANNED
CENTRALIZED IN INTEGRATED
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
THAT SIMPLIFY THE PUBLIC'S
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
IMPROVES THE SPEED AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE RESPONSE.
SB FOUR FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
REJECTS THIS.
SB FOUR THIRTY WILL DISMANTLE
EXISTING CENTRALIZED MEDICAL
PEACE SAP SUCH AS THOSE SERVING
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY STANISLAUS
COUNTY MERCED COUNTY AND TULARE
COUNTY.
AND WILL STOP LOCAL EMS AGENCIES
FROM CREATING ANY CENTRALIZED
MEDICAL DISPATCH CENTERS IN THE
FUTURE.
BECAUSE OF TAKING AWAY OUR
MEDICAL CONTROL AUTHORITY OVER
DISPATCH.
THE STATEMENTS BY THE BILL'S
SPONSORS MIX.
MISS CHARACTERIZE THE PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION EVALUATION OF THE
MESSAGE WAS BY LOCALLY MISS
AGENCIES.
AS AN EXAMPLE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY EMS AGENCY AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REDESIGNED ITS EMS
SYSTEM TO CREATE AN EXCLUSIVE
OPERATING AREA FOR AMBULANCE
SERVICE.
IT IS AS A SINGLE PUBLIC.
SAFETY ANSWERING POINT TO WRITE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL DISPATCH.
THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY.
ELIMINATE BLAME GAMES BETWEEN
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AMOS
PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
DISPATCH CENTERS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY. FOR
PATIENTS THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
TO ENSURE THAT THE CLOSEST
AMBULANCE.
IS ALWAYS DISPATCH THE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL JURISDICTION.
WHAT COLOR THE AMBULANCES WERE
WHAT UNIFORM THEY'RE WEARING?
THIS GOES AWAY WHEN WE LOSE
MEDICAL CONTROL THE DISPATCH
SYSTEM.
TODAY IS DESIGNED EACH LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRIMARY PIECE SEVEN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY ROUTES NINE
ONE CALLERS REQUESTING MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE THE COUNTY'S MEDICAL
DISPATCH CENTER.
THE MEDICAL DISPATCH CENTER
FOLLOWS LOCALLY MISSING SUPER
POLICIES THE TERMINATOR THE
PATIENT'S MEDICAL EMERGENCY
IMMEDIATELY INITIATE FIRST
RESPONSE TREATMENT BY
INSTRUCTING CALLERS. TO PERFORM
LIFESAVING INTERVENTION SUCH AS
CPR STOPPING PATIENTS FROM
LEADING OUT IN AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATION.
INSTRUCTING CHILDBIRTH WHICH WE
ALL HEAR ON THE NEWS REGULARLY
WHERE SOMEONE HAS A MEDICAL CALL
TAKER FALLING MEDICAL DIRECTION
OF PHYSICIAN.
HAS TAUGHT SOMEBODY TO DELIVER
BABIES.
JUST HAPPEN TO THE SEATS FOR
BOTH THE NICE TRAINS EACH P.
OFFICER THEY WILL HELP SOMEBODY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- RECENTLY
JUST TO DO THAT BUT IT ALSO
HAPPENS THROUGH NINE ONE CALL
SYSTEMS. SEVEN CAN COUNTY IS
FACE LAWSUITS OVER ITS
INTEGRATED EMS SYSTEM DESIGN
INCLUDING THE USE OF PRIVATE
MEDICAL DISPATCH CENTERS.
THE COURTS FOUND THAT THE
POLICIES ADOPTED BY THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WERE ADOPTED FOR
MEDICAL REASONS. FOR INTENDED TO
IMPROVE SPEED AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL RESPONSE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
STRENGTH IN THE COUNTY EMS
AGENCIES OVERSIGHT OF MARINES
MEDICAL DISPATCH ENHANCE ANIMALS
PROVIDER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
CONTRACTOR PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
IN PROVIDE FOR MORE EFFECTIVE
QUALITY ASSURANCE.
THOSE ARE THE COURT'S FINDINGS.
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE BILL'S
SPONSORS THAT LOCALLY MESS
AGENCIES THAT TO THE DESIGN EMS
SYSTEMS USING A PRIVATE IN ANY.
FORM NINE ONE MEDICAL DISPATCH
ARE PLACING PROFITS BEFORE
PATIENTS IN REDUCING SERVICES IN
CREATING FELLING SYSTEMS WE HAVE
TO GRAPH MALICIOUS INACCURATE.
IN SUMMARY I'D LIKE JUST TO
POINT OUT IF YOU READ.
THE LAST PART ON PAGE FOUR OF
THE AMENDED BILL.
IT SAYS THE PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY
MAY VOLUNTARILY CONSENT TO
FOLLOW POLICIES.
VOLUNTARY CONSENT IS NOT MEDICAL
DIRECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MICROPHONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STRONG
HENSCHEL HERE ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
IN PRINT.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
ARE ON GOING AND WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT A COMPROMISE CAN BE REACHED
HERE SOON WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BETSY
ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION.
THE SHERMAN OTHER MEMBERS POLIO --
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF
STANISLAUS SAN JOAQUIN SISKIYOU --
AND FRESNO I THINK THE AUTHOR --
FOR APPARENTLY EXEMPTING FRESNO
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR OF FOR
EXEMPTING CINNAMON THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE -- BUT WE STILL DO
HAVE THREE COUNTIES THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO LARRY COUNTIES
IMPOSE BILLS LIKE THIS IN THE
PAST SO THEY'RE STILL LITTLE
WORK TO DO BUT LOOK FOR TO THAT
THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. SEVEN ANDERSON ON WE HAVE
THE SAN MATTEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ARE THE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A CENTER GROVE
A REMIX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS --
SO IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED WOULD
PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCIES BE
PERMITTED TO ACT OUTSIDE OF THE
MEDICAL CONTROL OF THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
AGENCY.
OR MEDICARE'S PRODUCTIVITY.
CHRISTIE OR THERE ARE EXPERT A
GIVE YOU FURTHER DETAIL Là.
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT ONE SHOULD ANSWER JUST
QUESTION I DID HEAR THE QUESTION
IF THIS BILL SO IF THIS BILL IS
ENACTED IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW.
WITH THE PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCIES
DOING THE NINE ONE ONE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW I THINK THAT. 90% OF
THAT IS DONE BY PUBLIC SERVICE
AGENCIES ARE CORRECT.
SO IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED DOES
IT CHANGE ANYTHING THAT IS
DIFFERENT.
WITH DOES EVERYTHING STAY THE
SAME LIKE RIGHT NOW I KNOW NINE
ONE ONE I HAD THIS CONVERSATION
WITH CHRIS YESTERDAY WE ALL KNOW
HOW I FEEL ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS
AND THEM PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCIES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT NINE ONE ONE YOU KNOW I
THINK SHOULD PROBABLY BE UNDER A
PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCY PURVIEW.
BUT I AM CONCERNED THAT IT DOES
TAKE THE MEDICAL CONTROL AWAKE
FROM LOCAL AUTHORITY.
AM I AM CONCERNED WHICH I DIDN'T
HEAR YESTERDAY S. ABOUT AS THE
THE PATCHWORK SCENARIO WHERE THE
CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT BILL TO
DISPATCH FOR LEASE COUNTY
OUTSIDE THE REAL COUNTY AREA
SUBJECT.
TO NOT THE SAME THINGS BUT MY%
UNDERSTANDING IS IT
SIMULTANEOUSLY TO AND IS THAT
NOT CORRECT.
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN
THE CALL COMES IN WE'RE A HOW
THE PROCESS HAPPENS IF SOMEONE
CALLS AND I WANTED TO BE THE
GHOST OF POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
TRANSFERRED OUT OF OUR COUNTY.
TWO DIFFERENT DISPATCH CENTER
WITH A PROCESS THE CALL THE TIME
WE SET TAKES PLACE WE DON'T KNOW
WE GET VIA CAD TWO CAD LINK.
THAT INFORMATION TO OUR DISPATCH
CENTER WE HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
A DISPATCH PROCESS AS THE OTHER
COUNTY DOES-- BUT WE DON'T GET
THE LIVE COLOR WHICH GIVES US
THE INABILITY TO HAVE THAT
SOMETIMES PERTINENT INFORMATION
DURING OUR RESPONSE -- WITHOUT
HAVING THAT -- THAT LIVE COLOR
IT REALLY AT IT IF IT.
TAKES AWAY OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE BEST SERVICES SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
WE COULD DISPATCH RIGHT NOW FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTY FTP BUT AT
THIS TIME BY PROCESS WE DON'T
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY NOW WE DO
STILL FALL UNDER MEDICAL FORTY
UNDER OUR TO PLAN FOR EMS UNDER
OUR DISPATCH SYSTEM WE REPORT.
ANYTIME THAT WE HAVE EM D. TYPE
CALLS ARE CALLS FOR SERVICE THAT
REQUIRE EMS RESPONSE REPORT THAT
TO OUR LIVES ARE SO THE SYSTEM
PROCESS WHEN IT CHANGED THE
DIFFERENCE WOULD BE.
WHO HAS THE LIVE CALLER?
OKAY SO RIGHT NOW LIKE I SAID
90% OF AT DISPATCHES IS
CONTROLLED BY AND BY
FIREFIGHTERS OR PEOPLE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE RIGHT IT'S FRESNO WHEN A
FEW EXEMPTIONS.
UNDER THAT SCENARIO RIGHT NOW
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT YOU
DON'T GET THE LIVE CALL DIRECT
ANYONE TO LIVE CALL YOU LIKE A
LOT OF COLOR IN GETTING THE LIVE
CALL SORRY.
AND GETTING THE LIVE CALL WILL
YOU STILL BE UNDER THE MEDICAL
PER VIEW OF THE COUNTY AUTHORITY
TO WHERE THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON YES HOUSE.
WE HAVE A MEDICAL DIRECTOR THAT
OVERSEES ALL MEDICAL OPERATIONS
WITHIN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY THEY
SAID THE POLICY THE PRACTICE
WHAT TYPE OF AN EMT STRUCTURE WE
HAVE.
WHAT TYPE OF THE SYSTEM WE USE
OUR CABS SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED ALL THAT IS UNDER
THEIR THEIR REGULATION WE REPORT
TO THEM ON A MONTHLY BASIS MANY
SPECIFIC FINDINGS IN REGARDS TO
EMS?
SO IT THE THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
SYSTEM WOULD BE THE LIVE CALL IN
A LIVE CALL WOULD NOT BE
TRANSFERRED TRANSFERRED OUT OF
OUR COUNTY TO A PRIVATE DISPATCH
CENTER HE LEFT IN OUR COUNTY.
FOR OUR RESOURCES TO TO BE
DEPLOYED THEN.
SO CAN I GET A RESPONSE BECAUSE
THIS OKAY WE HAVE ALREADY MADE
IT CLEAR THAT I REALLY THINK
THAT NINE ONE ONE BELONGS IN A
PUBLIC AGENCY I DO -- I DO BUT I
AM VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL AND LOSING THAT
AND ESPECIALLY THE PATCHWORK
EFFECT BECAUSE I'VE BIG CITIES
BUT I GOT I GO ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE NEEDLES I GOT A NEEDLE
THERE IS ON THE BORDER RIGHT AND
THERE'S OT BIG CITIES DOWN.
THERE SO I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR PIECE --
YES MR TURNED ME OUT VERY DATING
ON BEHALF OF C. SACK AGAIN AND
THOSE ARE HAT'S THE CORE OF OUR
CONCERN BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE WE NEED TO
LOOK AT IT COUNTY WIDE.
AND CURRENTLY THAT AUTHORITY --
AND AND KATHLEEN HERE DOCTOR
CONFIRM IS A MEDICAL DIRECTOR
AND SO.
THE THE GENTLEMAN IS CORRECT
THAT THEY DO SERVE UNDER THE
MEDICAL CONTROL AND REPORT THESE
THINGS TO THE COUNTY CURRENTLY
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
EXEMPT THEMSELVES FROM THAT AND
THAT LAST CLAUSE WE MENTIONED IN
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
MORE OPEN TO TALKING WITH THE
SPONSORS ABOUT AMENDMENTS --
ALLOWS OF IF THIS BILL WERE TO
PASS THE FIRE DEPARTMENT COULD
SAVE VOLUNTARILY NO WE DON'T
WANT IT HERE TO THAT -- WE DON'T
NEED TO WE MAY REPORT SOME
THINGS OR YOU MAY REPORT ALL BUT
IT REALLY TAKES WITH THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
HAVING A DOCTOR HAVE OVERSIGHT
ON THE SYSTEM.
YES MA'AM -- SO ERRORS WILL
HAPPEN ERRORS DO HAPPEN THEY
HAPPEN BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
DISPATCH.
AND THE CONCERN IS THAT WHEN
IT'S BEING DEALT WITH ONLY BY
THAT ENTITY THAT'S DOING THE
DISPATCH THAT THAT TRUE
OVERSIGHT ISN'T HAPPENING WE
ALREADY HAVE A VERY GOOD --
OVERSIGHT AND PLEASE INCLUDING --
AND A LOT OF PLACES THE CMT
WHERE THE DISPATCHER GIVES
MEDICAL -- ADVICE TO SOMEONE
BEFORE THE AMBULANCE I EVEN GETS
THERE -- WHEN THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN APPROPRIATELY THAT'S
REALLY SOMETHING THAT'S ON THE
DOCTOR LEVEL THAT I THINK NEEDS
TO BE INVOLVED IN I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THAT'S MY CONCERN?
I'M ALSO.
JUST TO SAY WITHIN THE I'M I
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC DISPATCH --
BUT THE OTHER CONCERN IS THAT
DOES THIS FRAGMENT TO EACH
SPECIFIC -- FIRE AGENCY BECAUSE
STUDIES SHOW OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE AND EVEN WITHIN THIS -- IN
IN OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
CENTRALIZING DISPATCH HELPS THAT
PATIENT CARE IT HELPS -- THE
SPEED OF CARE TO GET TO THOSE
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY IN PATIENTS
THAT WE KNOW NEED FAST RESPONSES
CARDIAC ARREST.
DROWNINGS SEIZURES THEY ALL NEED
SOMEONE QUICKLY BECAUSE THEY
NEED MEDICINES AN INTERVENTION --
ALSO BY PROVIDING DISPATCH
INSTRUCTIONS -- TO PATIENTS THAT --
TO SEE THE CALLER FOR SOMEONE IN
CARDIAC ARREST SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
BYSTANDER CPR THAT'S PERFORMED
IT GOES UP.
EXPONENTIALLY THERE'S NOT THAT
MUCH BY SENIOR CPR THAT HAPPENS
UNLESS A DISPATCHER TELLS THEM
TO DO IT -- BUT THAT WE ALSO
KNOW IMPROVE SURVIVAL.
I I JUST HAVE ONE MORE IT SORRY
GO AHEAD CHRISTIE SORRY MISS
FROM SORRY THROUGH THE CHAIR IF
I MAY JUST TWO QUICK POINTS.
THE COMMITTEE ESTAS TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS OF THAT VOLUNTARY
CONSENT IS TO REDUCE SERVICES
PURSUANT TO THE MEDICAL CONTROL
POLICIES OF THE COUNTY.
SO IT'S NOT TOO DOES DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT IT'S TO DO LESS THAN
THE OTHER WAS.
OTHERWISE WOULD DO IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
VOLUNTARILY REDUCING THE SERVICE
THANK YOU FOR THE RECORD
RECOMMENDATION AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT OUR INTENT WAS --
AND SECONDARILY.
BUT BY THE BILL SAYING YOU COULD
ONLY CONTRACT TO ANOTHER PUBLIC
ENTITY IT IS NOT TAKING THE
DECISION AWAY FROM THE COUNTY TO
HOW TO COVER THE ENTIRE COUNTY.
THEY'RE JUST IT JUST SAYS DON'T
GIVE IT TO A PRIVATE PROVIDER.
SO THAT ALL THE COUNTY CAN STILL
PULL ALL THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS TO
THE TABLE AND SAY HOW ARE WE
GONNA DO DISPATCH IN THIS COUNTY.
ARE WE GOING TO MAKE SURE EVERY
SQUARE MILE IS COVERED AND EVERY
EVERY RESPONSE IS IS ADEQUATE
FOR EVERY ONE OF OUR CITIZENS
AND THAT'S THAT'S THEIR JOB NOW.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD.
THANK YOU KEEP IN PLACE I I HAVE
ONE QUESTION JUST BECAUSE I
WANNA BE CLEAR ON INFRASTRUCTURE
TYPE YEAH OKAY SO IS IT TO THE
LIVE COLOR NOW GOES TO NINE ONE
ONE THE POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT
GOES TO CENTRALIZE STATION AND
THEN IT'S DISSEMINATED OUT.
AND FIRE AMBULANCE WHOEVER
RESPONSE FROM A COUNTY WIDE
LEVEL CORRECT CORRECT WHEN IT
GOES TO EITHER YOUR FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR THE CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR A FIRE DISTRICT OR
IF IT IF IT'S BROKEN AT IS IS IT
A IS IT A FLIP OF A SWITCH.
IS IT A NINE ONE EIGHT IS THE
CALL DIRECTED SENT LIKE HOW IS
HOW IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THE HOW IS IT IMPLEMENTED.
I GUESS HOW DO YOU CHANGE IT.
THIS IS A TNCS WHICH TO BRING
THAT THE NINE ONE CALLS TO OUR
DESERVE AT T. JUST HAS A FLIP A
SWITCH AND HISTORICALLY SPEAKING
WE DISPATCH THOSE COUNTY
AGENCIES BEFORE.
OKAY.
I WOULD SAY FOR ENTITIES THAT
HAVE OR ARE CURRENTLY DOING
DISPATCH IT IS A VERY SIMPLE
PROCESS FOR ENTITIES THAT MAY
NOT HAVE EVER DONE IT OR MAYBE
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE I
THINK THAT THERE WOULD BE A COST.
AND A TIME FOR THEM TO GET UP TO
SPEED WE APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER PLACES OF
MADE IN THE ONES THAT DO HANDLE
DISPATCH FOR US -- BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT EVERY AT LIKE NEEDLES
OR OTHER SMALL AREAS OR EVEN
SMALLER FIRE DISTRICTS WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THE DISPATCH PER SE.
IS THAT YES SIR.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT IF I COULD
JUST ADD TO THAT YOU PART OF OUR
CONCERN IS NOT THAT YOU CAN
BUILD A SYSTEM THAT HAS MULTIPLE.
POINTS OF DISPATCH WITHIN IT BUT
IT COMPLICATES THE SYSTEM IN A
MEXICAN THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DROP A CALL AND HAVE A FAILED
RESPONSE INCREASE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
CHOSE TO HAVE A SINGLE
CENTRALIZED DISPATCH CENTER SO
POSSIBILITY.
AIR STILL OCCUR NOT SAYING
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BUT THERE'S
A WAY OF IDENTIFYING IT IN
CORRECTING IT UNDER THE MEDICAL
DIRECTION THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR.
AND IF THE BILL.
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE MEDICAL
DIRECTORS AUTHORITY WHICH I
THINK IT DOES BUT IT'S PLAIN
READING.
IF THEY JUST WANT TO PROHIBIT
CONTRACTING OUT TO TO A PRIVATE
ENTITY.
THEN YOU CAN DROP ALL THE
AMENDMENTS TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE.
BECAUSE CHANGING HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE IS ABOUT RESTRICTING
MEDICAL CONTROL.
SLICE PLAIN PLAIN LANGUAGE
[inaudible]
AND SO.
A CITY CENTER HERTZBERG THAT'S
RIGHT HAVE A PROBLEM AND I KNOW
YOU GET THE BILL OUT WITHOUT MY
THOUGH TO I'M NOT YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT THAT BUT I REALLY
THINK THAT THERE IS.
AN ISSUE THERE IF IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT A PUBLIC AGENCY
IS IN CHARGE OF NINE ONE ONE
THEN LET'S MAKE THE BILL ABOUT A
PUBLIC AGENCY IN CHARGE OF NINE
ONE ONE BUT NOT MESS WITH.
THE LOCAL CONTROL OF MEDICAL
CONTROL THAT HAS OVERSIGHT -- I
KNOW MY COUNTY BURSARY
SPECIFICALLY TO LARRY WAS HERE
TO OPPOSE IT.
AND THEY WANT MEDICAL CONTROL
AND AND I HAD NOT HEARD THE
PATCHWORK OF PORTION OF IT THAT
KIND OF BOTHERS ME A LITTLE BIT
I'M A LITTLE BIT MORE AT EASE
NOW THAT I KNOW YOU JUST FLIP A
SWITCH IT GOES TO YOU SO.
BUT CAN YOU FLIP THE SAME
SWITCHING GO TO NEEDLES
CALIFORNIA OR YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW MODESTO MERCED IN OUR RULED
VALLEY AREAS -- I THINK IT
SHOULD BE IN THE PUBLIC PURVIEW
I DO THAT'S ONE THING POLICE
FIRE AND NINE ONE LINE SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE IN THE PUBLIC.
PURVIEW BUT NOT AN I DON'T THINK
IT I THINK THERE SHOULD BE SOME
TYPE OF LOCAL CONTROL WITH
ESPECIALLY THE MEDICAL.
OVERSIGHT.
SO THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS LET ME ACTUALLY IS
STILL LEFT ME IN THE MIDDLE OKAY
AND I KNOW WE HAVE SOME OF THE
CUT BY JUST ONE MAKE.
THIS CLEAR FINE I REALIZED --
MAYBE SOME DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
BY THE OPPOSITION BUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN THAT
OUR COMMITTEE WORKED ON WAS FOR
THE VERY PURPOSE.
OF TRYING TO ENSURE COUNTY
MEDICAL DIRECTORS RETAIN.
MEDICAL CONTROL.
SO THAT THAT'S THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE BUT THE AUTHOR TOOK
WERE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
COMMITTEE CRAFTED I REALIZED OR
MAYBE SOME -- DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION BY THE OPPONENTS BUT
THAT WAS THAT WAS THE VERY
INTENTION OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT --
WE ASKED THE AUTHOR TO TAKE
WHICH IS ACCEPTED SO.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A COPY OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- BUT I DID WANT TO
MAKE THAT STATEMENT DECLARE FIVE
WHAT WE HAD DONE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT -- THE
ONLINE -- SORRY.
IT'S A CENTER TADA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I YOU
KNOW I REALLY WANT TO THANK -- A
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR HIS EFFORTS
IN WORKING ON THIS BILL -- AS
YOU CAN SEE.
THIS BILL IS -- IT'S A LITTLE
BIT COMPLICATED WHEN IT COMES TO
RURAL CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY MY
SENATE-DISTRICT RIGHT BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SUPPORT.
I HAVE FRESNO COUNTY FIRE THAT'S
IN SUPPORT BY ALSO IN OPPOSITION
HAVE THE COUNTY FRESNO -- IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT IN MY EXPERIENCE
AND I'M.
IN IN IN IN CONCEPT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I WILL
SUPPORT IT TODAY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT IT BUT I'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON REALLY
A TRUST SEEN ON A SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THAT REALLY PERTAIN.
TO RURAL CALIFORNIA AND AND IN
MY SENATE DISTRICT -- YOU KNOW
MY EXPERIENCE BEING ON THE ON ON
THE COUNT ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
I'M A SMALL YOU KNOW.
CITY IS THAT -- WE HAVE BUDGET
PROBLEMS AND A WE WANT LOCAL
CONTROL AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGE AND CONTRACTING OUT
BECAUSE WE DID THAT'S WHAT WE
COULD AFFORD -- IS THAT
SOMETIMES SO THAT WE CONTRACTED
OUT WITH DIDN'T.
WHEN WE CALLED AND YOU KNOW FOR
NINE ONE ONE PAID INTO NO THE
STREET OR THEY WEREN'T FAMILIAR
WITH?
WITH THE CITY -- OR THE STREETS
FOR YOU KNOW CERTAIN LOCATIONS
AND AND AND THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THE PEOPLE I
REPRESENT BUT IT'S ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW TO HAVE THAT THAT LOCAL
CONTROL BUT LIKE I SAID IT'S
IT'S NOT -- IT'S IT'S
COMPLICATED FOR RURAL CALIFORNIA
AND AND I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
YOU KNOW WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THESE.
THESE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO TO MY SENATE
DISTRICT BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS IN THIS AND YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT TWENTY THREE CITIES
FOR COUNTIES FRESNO COUNTY BEING
ONE OF THEM -- BUT A STE I
REPRESENT TO LARRY KING'S AND
CURRENT AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- SO -- SEARCH FOR GRANDMA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFFS AND
CERTAINLY I'M SURE YOU KNOW AND
YOU'LL YOU'LL ADDRESS -- YOUR
OPENNESS TO CONTINUE WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION I MEAN I THINK WE
TRIED -- WITH OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF TO TRY TO CRAFT AMENDMENTS.
TO REACH THE GOALS THAT WERE
EXPRESSED THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
MEDICAL CONTROL ON ME AS A
PHYSICIAN AND I APPRECIATE.
COLLEAGUES HERE -- THAT -- WE
HAVE TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN I
UNDERSTAND FROM THE PROPONENTS
THE SHARE THE SAME GOAL AS WELL
BUT SO THAT ASPECT OF IT AND
THEN AND STILL WATCH EVEN THE
AIMS OF YOUR BILL WHICH IS TO
ENSURE THAT I THINK -- I
APPRECIATE US -- GROW SAYING
THAT -- I THINK MANY OF US FEEL
THAT. NINE ONE ONE IS SORT OF A
CALL OR YOU KNOW PUBLIC SAFETY
FUNCTION AND SHOULD RESIDE IN A
PUBLIC ENTITY SO -- BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THERE AND
WE DO HAVE THOSE ACT MEDICAL
TOOLS -- CAN NAIL OVERSIGHT BY
THE IT THEMSELVES SO WAS SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN TRY BUT WE KNOW
OUR COMMITTEE TRY WORKS TO TRY
CRAFT AS AMENDMENTS I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR ACCEPTING THOSE.
AMENDMENTS TO TO TO TRY IT TO
ACHIEVE THAT BUT IF THERE'S MORE --
YOU KNOW WE LOOK FOR TO THE
CONVERSATION AND TO TO TO
FURTHER CLARIFY THAT -- WITH
THAT -- IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY -- CENTER DRAWS THOSE MOVED
TO WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES DOES
YOUR FROM MOMENT TO WE HAVE AN
EXPERT HERE WANTED TO ANSWER ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS AND GET ANSWERS
LIKE TO MAKE SURE HIS.
THOUGHTS ARE SHARED IN THE
RECORD OKAY AT YES PLEASE.
ONE FAR TOO SERIOUS STOCKTON I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED BECAUSE OF
SELECT WAS TO PART.
THE ONE QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING WHEN YOU'RE SPEAKING WITH
CHIEF JOHNSON WAS AS IT RELATES
TO SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
THERE ARE OTHER CITIES OF HIGH
PERFORMING TO SPECIMENS WHERE
THE NINE ONE ONE CALL COMES INTO
A PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS.
IN GOES TO THAT CITY.
AND IN THAT PARTICULAR PUBLIC
AGENCY DISPATCH THAT IS THE BEST
PRACTICE.
THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN OUR CITY IS AT NINE
ONE ONE COMES IN IT GETS
TRANSFERRED TO A SECOND PARTY IN
HIM.
BACK TO US IS SO THAT CALL IS
TRANSFERRED ONCE IN A COMES BACK
VIA COMPUTER -- TO US WHEN WE
DISPATCH ENOUGH WITH CHIEF
JOHNSON WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
INTERACTIONS SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
I GET ALL THE OTHER COUNTIES
THAT YOU GUYS WERE TALKING ABOUT --
WE ARE DEFICIT PORT OF IMPROPER
GOVERNMENTS AS IT RELATES.
TO THE MEDICAL MAKING SURE THAT
IS PROPER EMT BUT I ALSO WANT TO
LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THE
BEST PRACTICES WHEN NINE ONE ONE
COMES IN THAT ITGOES DIRECTLY.
TO THE FIRE AGENCY THAT IS
DISPATCHING AND THEN THEY DO THE
PROPER EMT AND DISPATCH.
AND WE MENTION ABOUT A STATE I
WORK FOR THE CITY OF LOSVEGAS
CART COUNTY WHERE WE PROCESS A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALLS.
IN ONE CENTER COMING THROUGH --
CALL COMES FROM THE PEACE UP
DIRECTLY TO OUR CENTER AND WE
PROCESS IT.
IN THE WORKS OKAY AND SO THE
ONLY THING THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WE GOT GOING ON HERE SO I
CAN COUNTIES THAT IT'S PEACE OUT.
TO CONTRACTOR IN AND BACK TO THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT SAYS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT PICTURE WAS
CLEAN -- AND AND THAT IT WAS
PAYING FOR IT AND AGAIN -- WHICH
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IN AND WE WILL ENSURE AND FIRE
DEPARTMENT IS ALWAYS WANT TO
MEET WE'RE ALWAYS HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT OUR DISPENSERS.
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO LOCAL
INTO SUCH WANT TO PAINT A
PICTURE FOR YOU.
HEY I APPRECIATE YOU POINTING
THAT OUT BECAUSE I DIDN'T GET
HEAR THAT RESPONSE AND I DO
UNDERSTAND IT I DO I DO
APPRECIATE IT AGAIN LIKE MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO.
APPROVED REPRESENT LARGE RURAL
AREAS THAT ME -- HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM WITH THIS BUT I
REPRESENT CITIES WHO WANT IT SO --
I'M REALLY HOPING THAT -- YOU
CAN WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AGAIN I
BELIEVE THAT.
SHOULD BE A PUBLIC ENTITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT RESPONSE TO NINE
ONE ONE POLICE DEPARTMENT
HOWEVER IT'S TIME IT SHOULD BE
DEFINITELY PUBLIC AGENCY.
AND SO I I HOPE YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH AN ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD BRING BOTH SIDES
TOGETHER THANK YOU.
UP TO ADDRESS A QUESTION.
UP.
THIS IS COME UP OF A FEW TIMES
ABOUT A RURAL AREA -- I SEE HERE
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
SMALL CITIES WERE ROLL
METROPOLITAN -- AN ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS SO I I DON'T GET
WHAT WHAT'S THE DANGER OF THIS --
OF THIS PROPOSAL TO RULE AREAS.
WHY CENTER WHY IS THAT?
I THINK IT'S A VERY SOON I DON'T.
THE THING THAT ENDANGERS IF IT'S
A CITY VERSUS A RURAL AREA BUT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT FROM THE
REPRESENTATION HERE.
I THINK IS IS I THINK THAT
REALLY HELPS A SPRINGBOARD INTO
THE THOUGHT SO ON SURE ON THE
CLOSE OF THE COMMITTEE.
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU.
I WOULD SUGGEST OVER A THOUSAND
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IF I HAD
ADAM ALL UP.
A BOTH LABOR AND MANAGEMENT THIS
IS NOT JUST THE THE THE
FIREFIGHTERS DESERT PUSH CHEESE
TOGETHER WHY BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IN THEIR HEART.
AND WHAT YOU SAID SENATOR GOAL
OVER USUALLY GERMAN PAN IS
EXACTLY THIS THIS IS THE ESSENCE
OF PUBLIC SERVICE THIS IS THE
FRONT LINE THIS IS WHO GETS THE
CALL THIS IS WHAT IT FEELS LIKE
WHEN THERE'S A MISTAKE BECAUSE
IT'S CONTRACTED OUT.
ORDER MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES
RIGHT THERE ARE BUT THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE AREAS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
AND PUBLIC SAFETY THAT YOU DON'T
SCRIMP ON THAT WE CAN'T MAKE A
MISTAKE ON AND SO WHAT YOU HAVE
IS A COALITION.
OF AN UNBELIEVABLE NUMBER OF
PROFESSIONAL PEOPLE WHO AT THEIR
CORE AND WHAT THEY'RE ABOUT AND
WHY THEY HAVE THESE JOBS WHEN I
TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT THE
FIRES FIRES SO STATION HE TALKS
TO ME WITH GREAT EMOTION AND
PASSION.
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC AND HE DOES HE ONLY SEES
THESE KINDS OF MISTAKES.
AND ALL OF HIS MEMBERS AND THE
CHIEF SEE THESE MISTAKES THAT'S
WHAT THEY'VE TRAVEL FROM ALL
CORNERS OF THE STATE SO YES
THERE'S CHALLENGES THERE'S
ALWAYS CHALLENGES IN MANAGEMENT
OF ORGANIZATIONS AND WHEN YOU
HAVE SPLIT BETWEEN COUNTIES
WE'RE TRYING TO MANAGE MONEY.
VERSUS PEOPLE WHO ARE RESPONDING
TO THE CALLS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
HERE TODAY YOU ARE SEEING THIS
ISSUE I STAND WITH THEM I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- CHIEF THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE CLARIFICATION I
JUST -- SO WE HAVE MOTION FOR
CENTER DRAWS SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AMENDED -- SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CAN I AYE STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
TERRAZZO I'D GROWTH GROUP I HER
TADO.
A TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO HI.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK
YOU SIR THANKS FOR MUCH.
OKAY SO -- AND FINALLY WE HAVE --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS ON
CONSENT SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR THE
ONLY ITEM CONSENT IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FOR TITLE I LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I EIGHT X. CENTEL OWNERS
OUT NINE ZERO SO NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF STARTING WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWO FOURTEEN
BY CENTER DOT SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS --
TADO [inaudible]
HELLO I LABOR AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
YES SAID TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS BONDING HI.
KATE THAT THOSE OUT NINE ZERO
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
THREE SEVENTY THREE BY CENTER
HERTZBERG A SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE AYE MONNING [inaudible]
MONNING HI.
THE BILL IS ALSO OUT NINE ZERO
AND FINALLY ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER
RUBIO SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS TORONTO.
BROUGH I HER TATO.
TITLE II MORNING MORNING I THE
BILL IS OUT.
NINE ZERO OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR THIS
HEARING THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU